hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm a property millionaire but in this
video it isn't about me it's about me
sharing the top seven habits of property
millionaires so if you copy and study
these habits then maybe you will become
a property millionaire too if you like
my videos the first thing you need to do
to become a property millionaire is hit
the like button make sure you're
subscribed do that now habit number one
if you want to be a property millionaire
is simply viewing houses if you are a
property millionaire you're constantly
wanting to grow your portfolio you're on
right move you're talking to agents but
you're not just scrolling you're
actively out viewing properties i must
view probably around about 10 to 15
houses per month that might not sound
like loads but bear in mind i've been in
property for 13 years it's not like i'm
going hardcore
it's a habit it's just something that i
do maybe you might go shopping at the
weekend go out go to nando's look around
the stores while you're doing that i'm
out viewing houses and one of the
reasons why this habit is so important
is because when you view a property even
if that property isn't a good property
and it doesn't really work
i kind of think that one viewing leads
to another often the agent will say oh
i've got one down the road a property
viewing is not a property viewing it's
an appointment with an estate agent or a
landowner so property viewings is habit
number one habit number two is
constantly checking in with your power
team so your power team will it will
consist of your solicitor your
accountant your mortgage advisor your
architect your planning consultant your
letting agent the estate agents that you
do business with and as a property
millionaire you're constantly checking
in and just seeing if there's been any
updates in news regulations speaking to
your planning consultants about any new
things that are going on within the
council rules you're talking to your
mortgage advisors about what the
interest rates are doing the solicitors
about any new rules so
rather than watching the news and just
at 10 o'clock watching the 10 o'clock
news passively
property millionaires habitually and
actively are researching and finding out
the new laws rules information
specifically within their power team
that affect the property market habit
number three this one's so important
they all are habit number three is
regularly going to networking events
networking is one of the most powerful
aspects to becoming successful in
property when i started out in property
it wasn't just what i knew but it was
also who i knew and having a team around
you if you haven't got if you haven't
got a good network then who are you
going to check in with because you've
got no power team so again average
people might go to the club go to
parties go bowling
rich millionaires property millionaires
what they'll tend to do is go to go play
golf they'll go to a they'll get invited
by their bank to a a lunch a networking
lunch they'll be going off to networking
organizations giving keynote speeches
attending events to deliberately find
business associations that they can do
connections with habit number four is
reading books
reading is something that i cannot help
doing if if my wife takes me down to to
the shops and she's looking around at
the clothes and the handbags and we're
going shopping um i'll slip off and
she'll know just where to find me she'll
find me in w.h smith i'll be sat down in
the business section and i'll just be
lapping up some book i'll just be going
through the books and the more you learn
the more you earn let me tell you
something i hardly watch any tv a
massive part of my habits as a property
millionaire is continually reading
reading helpful books inspiring
biographies books that are gonna fill my
knowledge with useful information habit
number five this is so important all
property millionaires have this habit
you know if someone's rich because you
see them doing this and that is
protecting your time
property millionaires they know and
understand that their time is really
valuable so they're not going to do
things like go to the shops and do a
grocery shop no
they're either going to get someone to
do it for them or they're going to do it
online because it's much quicker and
time efficient they're not going to go
and cut their own grass wash their own
car because as a property millionaire
you are constantly habitually protecting
your time because if you've got a lot of
members of staff you've got loads of
tenants everyone's fighting for your
attention so you're putting together
processes and you're outsourcing this is
the word outsourcing your life
in my house
i don't even have to call the gardener
and say to the gardener hey what time do
you come in and go and go to the cash
point get some cash no it's all
systemized it's all outsourced the
gardener is on a direct debit he comes
the same time every week same time same
place everything's systemized
everything's outsourced i've outsourced
my entire life habitually so that i can
focus on the key important fundamental
things of creating wealth in my business
so habit number five is protecting your
time and outsourcing everything habit
number six
you'll probably see me all the time on
my phone right i'm always on my phone
and you might think i'd say habit number
six might be something like you know
detoxifying over social media and not
having your phone in you i'm always on
my phone and let me tell you what i'm
doing a lot of the time on my phone i'm
not ashamed to say this i'm not
embarrassed to say i'm checking my bank
i've got money coming in constantly
every few minutes i've got whether it be
a tenant or something i'm just
constantly checking refreshing and it's
not because i love money or i'm obsessed
with money but it's because i believe
that what you focus on expands if you're
a property millionaire part of your
habit will just be checking the bank in
the same way the pretty girls that post
on instagram they'll be checking their
likes how many likes did this get that's
what's important to them
what's important to you and what you
focus on is what will it magnify and
expand in your life if you're broke and
you've not got that much money in your
bank you're not going to be checking
your bank it's going to be depressing
right you're going to be like i don't
want to check when you're a property
millionaire there's nothing more
enjoyable than just being like oh wow
you know if you've got service to
combination properties which we've got a
lot of like every few hours like bang
bang bang bookings coming in tenants
paying rent developments refinance money
coming in big clumps of money but so i'm
always checking my bank account and i
think that is a habit of all property
millionaires
lastly
habit number seven
is
protecting your company
yes it's important to protect your time
but it's also important to protect who
you're spending time with when i was
broke when i was young i didn't think
about who i was spending time with if
someone said to me oh do you want to go
out should we do something you want to
get lunch i used to think do i like this
person do i jail with this person do i
connect with this person do i enjoy
being around this person those are not
things i ask myself right now now i
think
do i want to be like this person
is this person rooting for me to win is
this person going to be able to
collaborate with me and are we going to
be able to help each other get wealthy
it's a completely different type of
questions and a habit of a property
millionaire is not just protecting your
time but protecting
who protecting your who protecting who
you're spending your time with because
bad company corrupts good character and
it's so much easier to pull somebody
down than it is to pull somebody up
so i as a property millionaire i'm
habitually only spending time with
people whereby we're pulling each other
up and we're helping each other win so
there we have it folks those were the
seven habits of a property millionaire
maybe you can think of an eighth habit
if you can i want to know what the
eighth habit might be comment it below
if you enjoy my channel do me a favor
let's share this video around and help
people in property so if you like the
video it will help the algorithms and it
will help make this video go viral so
like the video drop a comment make sure
you're subscribed if you want to see a
video i did similar to this but about
how to become a millionaire the steps to
become a millionaire then you're
probably going to enjoy this video right
here don't forget to subscribe and if
you want to come and spend time with me
at the property millionaire intensive
i'm going to leave a link in the
description see you soon peace out god
bless
[Music]
you